and all of a sudden god's presence comes
all around me and i just feel him and he
communicates with me and he says paul
if you don't stop smoking marijuana
right now you'll never stop
wow and i picked it up and i looked at
it and i was like all right
so i went and i threw it out in the
trash
and i went and gathered all my
paraphernalia and i do it in the trash i
was like all right god i trust in you
i'm gonna stop how do you make a choice
between following your dreams and
following jesus find out on this episode
of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us again at led live we got a
special guest with us today this is paul
better known as mouse bear
but you know i had a past of being in a
band so me and him kind of connected
because mouse bear was in a band and
he's got a really cool story so i met
him through youtube because you watch
our show a lot and man your story just
blew my mind and i said we gotta hear
this on the show so tell us a little bit
about your background man what got you
into music and tell us a little bit
about where'd that name come from mouse
bear wellspare yeah well my
back in 2001
i lived in a small town
and i worked for the dnr and i would
work four out four four on three off
and i worked 10 hours a day and then all
my extra time i'd get to go to a coffee
shop and there was a cool band that
would play psychedelic funk so i'd
really get down with it i just look at
these guys like wow
i can do that yeah i wish i could do
that you know
and so
one night i had a dream while i was
living there and i saw him and
in my dream i come to and there's a
snare drum between my knees with a set
of sticks on there a drumsticks and i
look around and it's a full drum set
with all the symbols and everything and
i'm like what and i'm looking around and
i'm on the stage with six or seven other
musicians and they all got different
instruments and i look further and then
we're about 11 foot higher than heads as
far as the eye could see
all these people and then the leader of
the band was like okay one two three
four hit it so i went to go grab the
drumsticks and come in on the downbeat
yeah dream over
dream over okay reality starts and so
i just got up and i went to go get
breakfast and i was in the mess hall
that we all got fed at and and i was
just waiting in line just banging on
stuff she's like
like i think i knew what i was doing and
it comes like hey i didn't know you were
a drummer and i said
well
i'm not yet but one day i will be so you
didn't even you you weren't musically
inclined like you didn't play drums
already no they wouldn't even let me
join music class in high school because
i didn't start when i was younger oh wow
interesting yeah so
i said
okay
and i went with that and i just went
ahead and
i went
and i moved to missouri
for about a year i was looking for god
and they told me yeah i was in a mormon
religion where we had the book of mormon
and we would go through all that and i
know you guys had an episode like that
before on the show
and that really struck close to home and
i was like wow wow it's like so were you
raised in a christian home at all what
got you towards mormonism well
growing up my grandmother
she was like my favorite person in my
whole life she showed me unconditional
love and it was just like whoa i love
you is she a christian yeah yep cool and
so and she
well anyway she taught me how to have
faith in god
like we were in the woods and she
pretend like we're lost in our brother
and she goes oh we should get down on
our knees and we should pray for jesus
to show us the way home wow and so we'd
do that and then we'd find our way home
so at a very young age you know me and
my brother we got that
so anyways uh
i moved to missouri
to
do this whole closer
relationship with god
because that's where god was supposed to
come back his second time when he comes
back and so i went ahead and i moved out
there and my first job i had the first
paycheck i got i went ahead and i bought
a drum set
and i bought a book and it's like tap
tap
because of this dream you kind of felt
some significance to it like it was kind
of a foreshadowing of your future yeah i
was following my dreams well i clarified
too when you said jesus supposed to come
back to missouri yeah
that's a mormon believe right i believe
so okay that's not what we teach here on
this yeah jesus is coming to missouri
not utah
i know right yeah i don't know i think i
remember that to missouri yeah i have
never now we're at where in missouri
independence yeah that's what i thought
because there's a there's a mormon
temple there i've been by it yeah you
know we have a project called leaving
independence right
well the separation of degrees of
separation here oh but i'm still kind of
curious so your your grandmother was a
christian she grew you know taught you
growing up raised you up in the way you
should go
and she was actually in the in the
mormon church okay herself okay yeah i
was wondering where this connection with
mormon was yeah yeah that's interesting
yeah so yeah but what about the dream
what made you
you know what was that what made it so
significant or did you dream a lot or
well i didn't i yeah i always dream and
i can remember my dreams quite often
quite often but
this one was because i saw that band
that electric violet was the name of it
that's psychedelic [__] and i was just
like
you guys are so amazing i want to be
like you guys when i grow up and so when
i had that dream that that happened i
figured it was a sign that i needed to
follow
yeah and i was just like okay i can make
this happen i can make this happen
you wondered not to break your story but
you wonder how many times a dream comes
up like that somebody just has some
random thoughts or dreams or whatever
like this and then they just go that's a
song and they just follow their life and
they make that thing happen
i'm just you know of course i didn't
just tell you soul searching you know
yeah i was i was trying to get a closer
relationship with my creator yeah and i
was listening to people like the church
that i was in there like hey this is
where you should be because this is
where it's going to happen so i was just
trying to go there
while carrying this dream with me yeah
you know i'm like okay i'm going to have
this dream come true you know make great
music for people but uh yeah so i just
went ahead and i practiced for a little
bit and
and you know amateurs you know we just
kind of
make noise and hang out with each other
call it jamming jamming yeah we're
jamming
and so uh we went ahead and i did that
and
and then one day i found a book and it
was called songwriting for dummies and i
was just like okay
all right yeah okay it makes sense so i
started reading it and and it got to a
point where it's talked about chords
first first thirds and fifths and
and then x dentals and crescendos and
all this other stuff and i'm just like
what
and they said
if you don't know anything about this
you have to learn about this stuff
because this stuff right here is what
makes you a musician
yeah and so i was like okay well by this
time i moved back to michigan
and i was back in michigan because i
didn't figure
well actually before i moved back to
michigan i kind of well i went i moved
back to michigan i i know that for sure
and then
actually before i went to school to
learn
how to do
music
i actually went to
iowa
and i joined a cult
for like a month we were kind of cool it
was it was supposed to be another one of
those called another one of those
it was like little house on the prairies
what happened in missouri to get you in
a cult and yeah i mean are you actually
aware of that
or are you just searching for like i'm
gonna find god wherever okay so it's
still affiliated with this other church
i moved back to michigan and okay then i
decided to go to college
all right but i'm not going to college
for school i'm just going to college to
become an elementary school teacher
but then they kept teaching me the same
stuff over and over again and i was like
how long do you want me to stay here for
and how much are you going to pay me and
i'm just like
all right i'll see you guys later and
other distractions came into life to
where it takes your focus off of school
and so then i went ahead and i was
living with a member from the church
that i was involved with and they had
these books on their shelves
and a lot of them of the same one and i
was looking and i was like hey what are
you guys what's happening here like oh
you know we didn't want to bring it up
with you but since you asked there's a
place out in iowa to where there's a man
who has a german thurman
and he's german thurman you
it's like you
have like you look through something
and you can read on a plate and it
transfers it's like i think it's what
the mormons did
but and then you could
yeah it's interesting terms though
because that's what the hebrews used
that was the two
stones that sat on the
shoulders i think of the high priest
and you know one would like glow with a
circle halo and then the other one would
get cloudy well i never heard of this
before yeah is this yeah
no it really is it is it's in the box
yeah stuff would be no joke could ask
questions they'd ask god questions and
god would answer this is too close but
it's not like they're like
one would get cloudy and the other would
have like a halo oh okay yeah so halo
for yes cloudframe yeah i think so
people think the bible's boring man
but you can see also how the devil
counterfeits that very quickly you know
what i mean it's like oh wow he uses
this yes or no and now to our modern day
it's like an eight ball you know it's
like but it wasn't that it was something
different that they were calling the
same thing yeah yeah okay then so this
we called him grandpa he was the leader
of the clan if you will
so and it was it was kind of cool
because you'd go down this huge hill
and then you go down and there's like a
river that goes through it and then you
go over this nice bridge and there's all
these grass huts and everything like
that grasses yeah and so it was it was
really really attractive like people
living out of them yeah yeah we were
living out of them and
cutting wood you know without chainsaws
and you know splitting wood and stuff
like that just working pretty much like
so too long hours it was like yeah and
then the food they were feeding that's
how i was just like
okay guys what's up you know they're
like you should be grateful you know
with a lot of hours i'm working here
so uh
anyways
about a month after being there they're
like hey you know someone's going back
to mission you want to go back and visit
your family i was like all right cool
yeah i'll see you guys when i get back
all right cool
and so i plan on coming back but
a man that i trusted in my life
larry woods was with christian challenge
for the michigan state university and
the lcc chapters of christian challenge
he went ahead and
he talked me a little bit and he had a
way to talk him he was like a
therapeutic fellow he was really good
he's one of my favorite people
and so he went ahead and he talked to me
about he said hey what's it like and i
was like well they don't believe in paul
the apostles writings in the bible
and in the new testament yeah
so then you know at that time i really
don't know like torah keepers or was it
mainly to just the torah is it that type
of did they read the bible i think the
bible but yeah they had just the bible
but they're just not qualified
and so i think that was like but anyways
what i remember is like
grandpa he would all the men would go to
work and while the men was gone at work
all the wives would be back hanging out
with him and he kind of brainwashed them
all you know to a point to like and then
when he got the girls then when the
husbands came home you know it was just
like then uh you know it caused a little
bit of a havoc
but men would kind of submit to the
wives
or something i don't know what it was
exactly but i knew it was some kind of
manipulation that was happening wow
and so uh so i come back and knows larry
woods he's he finally tells me he's like
what do you need to stay back here
i said i need a vehicle and place to
stay
he was trying to get you out of the cult
yeah yeah
and so he said if i can get that to you
in two days before you leave will you
stay here and i said yeah i will
and so he called my dad he called my mom
he called my uncle he called all my
family and he got them all together
and he's like we need this and he called
the church members that when i was
living in east lansing they're like he
needs a place to stay who can help him
out so he i ended up going to this house
two days right before i was leaving
and
my mom's old great cougar was sitting in
the driveway and i was like what
and so i walk in and he says well
that great cougar out there that's your
mother cougar and i was like yes i
thought that was her cougar
and he said uh
and you can stay
at this church member's house
until you get on your feet again
will you stay that was a loving act man
that you really cared about your soul
and your destiny man super awesome
individual super awesome individuals so
yeah so
he uh
he fished me out got me out of there
and so i was like yeah i'm a man of my
worm i'll stay you know so i went ahead
and started life over again you know
started building up from from the bottom
and uh so anyways
that happened and then
and then i learned how to play the gem
bay i got to be in the christian
challenge group and i was playing the
gem bay by now what is christian
challenge because it reminds me of teen
challenge which is an addiction type
thing right is it similar christian
challenges
uh focused throughout the united states
and colleges
and same group though
no this is a different group yeah these
guys they they taught me how mormonism
really wasn't supposed to be
you know the religion of followers
and so you know in that first being a
mormon or into it and stuff like that
knowing like
i'm going through this
tough time like well why are you bashing
my religion my family you know all this
stuff so it's just like it was so hard
at that moment
you know to work now i can
and your grandmother's a mormon yeah
yeah she was yeah so so how did she kind
of take to all this or were you talking
to her through it um
i don't
she grandma was just always grandma she
was always all unconditional
love like all the time it's like i
it was only one time when you know she
blew up and we were
we were arguing over i don't think it
was the ketchup or something like that
nice and she grabbed it from us and
slammed on the table and busted went
everywhere
it was so funny though it was like so we
we relish on that now we're like yeah
remember that one day
but uh so we went ahead and uh
i went ahead and i went
and i was just going along in life and
then
i finally got to a point to where it was
like i've been through 31 jobs now
wow i had a head injury when i was a kid
i fell 65 feet head first on cement
and i died from it they came up picked
me up in a helicopter took me to the
hospital i died on the way and then they
put me on life support
how did you fall i mean what was the
situation situation okay there was a
parking lot on top and a parking lot on
bottom and there was three hills going
down
and got parking bricks set the scene
here for you and some grass at the
bottom with a few spotted trees and then
a little stream over here and then some
more grass and then sandy beach
so i was looking up we just got to camp
and the parents were like we were like
11 13
they're like go ahead go go do your
thing ride your bike so
we found some friends and i separated
from everybody and i looked at this
place when i wrote up and i was like
that is the awesomest obstacle course
i've ever seen
so i rode up to the top of it and i
looked down and i was like
[Music]
first sign first time that's about it
and so i was like okay i'll ride my
brakes down
and so i went and i let brakes go just a
little bit and i got over there and then
i squeezed the brakes and i was just
going real slow just hanging on
then got up to that second hill and i
was hanging out i was like okay okay
then i got to the third hill and i was
still holding on as soon as i got over
the edge of the third hill i let go of
the brakes and
right through the parking lot i got
right between the parking brakes on this
side of the parking lot and i almost got
to the other end of the parking lot but
i didn't make it so i stopped and i
looked back i was like if i don't ride
my brakes that much
i could probably make it to the sandy
beach and do my thing
so i rode back up finally got back up
there and i got to the top and i was
looking over
so i go over and let go the brakes a
little bit and
all right now i'm squeezing the brakes
and i'm coming down the first hill then
i come up the second hill and i'm like
okay squeezing the very experienced
brakes and come up and i then i let go
of the brakes when i'm coming down the
second hill and i pick up some speed and
i hit over that third hill and i just
get air and i'm off and i'm off and i'm
like whoa and then i land right before
the bottom of the third hill and it just
slingshots me right through this parking
lot and i'm just like standing up i got
it and i'm going through and just then i
get to the grass where the trees are and
i swear between the trees and i bunny
hop over that little stream and hit that
sand on that beach and
i spit sand up everywhere and i'm just
like yeah
so anyways i go back to the pool where
my brother is with all the friends and
they're swimming and i totally sand lot
on that fence and i'm just like you guys
got to come check this out this is
amazing and so
they come out hop on their bikes and we
ride up there and well it being the show
off
being the adrenaline junkie i am right
or the pride
i get up there and i back up about 16
feet
on the top parking lot then i stand up
on my bike and i just start pumping on
those pedals and i'm pumping i'm getting
closer and closer and closer to that
first hill where it starts going off and
i get to that first hill and
black
oh no i don't remember anything i just
bombed it yeah and so what happened is
my brother was there and he said what
happened was as i flew over that first
hill and i came down just on the edge of
that second hill and et'ed it from there
and 65 feet later from where they
measured it
i landed
and i slid 16 feet on the cement left a
big old blood trail
and so they sent the helicopter down
they picked me up and
i died on the way to the hospital but
they brought me back and then they put
me on
the
life support machine did you see a
tunnel no no
i don't see that i didn't see no time
at the end of the tunnel look at the
light
so i went ahead and uh
i woke up in the hospital
and i had a a little stuffed
duckbill platypus
and i named it zoey
and just a couple days ago i looked
online about the name what the meaning
of zoe was and it was
life it's great
great
and so i was just like oh wow that's
pretty sweet yeah and so yeah so i was
like why did i name that toy and then i
found out a couple days ago
but uh so yeah they had to i pretty much
forgot everything and they had to teach
me everything over again and
wow yeah so it was like i went to school
i had a helmet on my head i had a cast
on my arm broke my all my radius my eye
was crooked my tongue was crooked it was
yeah yeah it was just a piece of
recovery yeah
yeah what was it like when you
write out of that i mean were you
you could talk and stuff like you could
say words you just couldn't remember
like two plus two and stuff like that
right yeah and like i couldn't remember
how to divide or or do anything like
that and so even through all of that you
were able to come up with a name for
your stuffed animal yeah and choose zoey
right which means life yeah yeah i had
no idea even what that meant i was like
god had his hand on you amen brother
amen yeah so they fixed me up i went to
school and then i had to stay after
school and do this and while all the
other kids did this and that i had to go
to special classes and
so it was like yeah they really had to
work on me and i had to go to three
different therapies afterwards so it was
kind of it was kind of a tough deal uh
growing up as a kid and stuff like that
and then
they wouldn't let me into the music
program because i was too busy doing
this other stuff and so by the time i
get to high school i'm like
guys i want the music and they're like
can't have the music and i was just like
all right you guys are here to teach me
i i really like to be taught something i
like but
anyway so i had to go to college
to learn music and so there i am in
college
and i graduated high school with like a
.1 something or like that just to get
out i had to take extra class or credit
to get out
um
but then i got to college and now i'm
maintaining a 3.7 nice yeah
yeah just because i i was starting to
take all these music classes
and you know i'm getting up to the 80
credit mark right now with just all
music classes and they call me into the
office they say hey
it's it's about i was starting to take
music classes over again some of them
the second time you know because they
were running out of music classes
i was like sam i get better at something
and so they took me to the office and
they're like well
we noticed that uh
yeah you pretty much got over the music
credit hours that you need and you need
to start taking science class
math and government i was like what
i think for what and they're like
well
you need to be a well-rounded student i
was like huh
but
and i was just like
what i just came here for the music and
i was like well it's like why do i need
that they said so you can have a
certificate
and i think i don't want a certificate i
just came here for it to learn music
you know this is what i want to do and
they were just like no
but anyways while i was there i got to
do a
couple of awesome things i got to
i got taught how to play the classical
guitar from
the best classical guitar player in
michigan and fourth in the nation
which was amazing and also
a little really quick story is uh i went
to
i wanted to join the choir because i
wanted to learn how to sing
and i called up the choir teacher and i
was like hey i want to join your choir
class you go
well have you ever been in a choir
before i said
yeah i'm in a church choir he's like how
long it's about a couple months now and
he's like
do you know how to read music no i don't
he goes well
i think that you would try to sing but
you get frustrated because you don't
know what you're doing and that would
affect your voice
and then my pride just stands up again
like what are you trying to tell me i
can't do something
and so
i uh i went ahead and he said start and
take this class over here and it's just
an intro class and you can work your way
up within three or four classes and i'm
sick of myself three or four classes
i want to learn how to sing now
something like in the microwave you know
get it so i went ahead and
i had a vocal exercising cd that uh
a friend of the family gave me that
recorded a song with willie nelson i
think that was his name and
he uh he gave me this vocal exercise cd
it was like 55 minutes and so for five
to six
days out of the week i'd exercise my
vocals 55 minutes a day wow and because
i was just like oh good elude me you
know so like for three weeks it was like
that and my last name starts with the t
so it's at the end of the alphabet so i
have to wait for everybody else to go
through so i was watching the teacher as
he was saying all right okay stand up
do this put your shoulders back you know
just posturing everything seeing from
the diaphragm and stuff and like all
that stuff so so now three weeks into
the class i'm still exercising my vocals
four to five times a week for 55 minutes
a day
and it was my turn he called me up there
and i started singing when he was
playing his piano he's playing up and
down on his octaves and then finally he
just puts his hands to his side and he
says
why are you not in my choir class no i
said well you didn't invite me though
that's no excuse you need to be in my
choir class and i was just like all
right cool
and so i was like how am i going to do
that it's three weeks into the course he
goes go get an end drop for him sign it
let's we'll get you started so i was
like alright cool let's do it
and so i did it and two days later after
joining his class i found out that he
was taking his class to carnegie hall to
perform
and it was going to be
we are
like
the northern part there was a northern
of the united states a southern
a western and eastern part of the united
states of acquire from each part and
they brought us together and took us
over to new york and we practiced peace
for four days and then we had
new york opera house
singers with us and some of the
philharmonic they were there
and so we would all do our thing at
carnegie hall which is cool and also uh
so i was like
i tease a little bit when i say i got to
sing at carnegie hall before i even
learn how to read music yeah yeah so
that's not you i mean a lot of this
haven't even been there
yeah oh it's super awesome and we got
another time we went to germany got to
do like a two week tour had our own tour
bus which was kind of cool and we
started frankfurt went down to austria
and got to meet the uh
remember that movie the sound of music
yeah the the littlest girl doe mm-hmm
yeah she was there at her last
performance so i got her signature on my
music i was like
cool that's what up though so uh
so anyways i'm more i'm at college and
i'm trying to learn this music thing and
so i take it music theory one and two
and
a guitar class you know this and that
whatever
and i'm going
and i'm hanging out
in
in my hometown midland michigan
and i'm hanging out with this band
called brett mitchell and giant ghost
and this guy is amazing and i'm just
like whoa
i want to be like this guy because he's
playing the drums he's playing guitar
harmonica he's singing i'm just like
yeah
and so i went ahead and i was like
first day i met him i remember the
freeland music festival
and i was just like dude can i help you
carry something to your van
and then after that for like
years i was just like a volunteer roadie
with this guy just just trying to jumped
into it to see what was going on yeah
and i go to different towns with them
and stay at the hotels with them and
just you know do all this cool stuff and
just travel everywhere
and uh i always find that fascinating
that people can do that
like this happens a lot i've heard the
story a lot of people going you know i
really like this band and then they go
and hang out with the band and they tour
all over with the band
it's like you know i mean were they
paying for you to stay in the hotels
yeah at that point yeah they were paying
for me and
i remember i got my first dollar tip out
of the tip tires it's like it came out
to where everybody got even amount of
money but there was a dollar left over
and then the bass player was like hey
let's give the extra dollar to this guy
you know
yeah
for six months
so
i uh
and so it was a joke for a while you
know and stuff like that but uh so
anyways i'm at the bars now
watching these other
musicians coming through and there was a
fellow who came through eric nasa he
come in from illinois
and he had his own cds of original music
and i was like that's what i want to do
i want the original music because brett
mitchell was doing original music he had
three or four cds you know so it was
just like whoa
and so this guy coming his name was eric
nasa and
he
was passing through and i was like
i was like
what are you doing where are you where
are you off to he goes oh headed to
earthwork harvest gathering i said
what's that it's a music festival it's
like oh wow it's like it's all original
music i was like what
how much does it cost to get there you
know he's like you should come out there
and i was like oh i don't have no money
and uh he's just like oh don't worry
about it it's a donation you can just
donate for it that was like sweet all
right i can do that
i made a dollar i mean
i got this dollar
so i went ahead and uh
i
went to it the next day and he was just
flabbergasted he didn't even think i was
really gonna show up to this music
festival
and uh i showed up with a handful of
change
and i dumped it right on the table and i
went to go in and she was like wait a
minute wait a minute what what's this i
was like this is my donation
and she says this music festival cost
over a hundred dollars to get into and i
was just like
there's a hundred pennies there
tell them all one
two
and i went ahead and
and they said who told you that i said
some guy came through my town played
music last night
nasa and they're like oh eric nasa so
they called them up on the walking
walkie talkies and
eric there's a guy up here saying that
you talked to him last night at a bar
and said it was a donation this and that
and he's like oh yeah okay
and so
they let him in
and so i was so excited i was just like
i'm in i'm in
and so i was in and i volunteered to
work to help out because they kind of
they're like you know since you're here
you want to help out and i was like all
right cool what do you want me to do
like sit in the parking lot and just
point cars this way
all right i can do that
but uh i went ahead and i uh they have
these trash cans over there these metal
trash cans and i just kind of nothing
was in mine next to me so i just turn it
over and start
doing a little bit of drumming on this
trash can because that's what my
favorite michigan musician brett
mitchell used to do you just beat on
everything you know so it's like okay
anything's instrument yeah and so i just
found that i was like doing it and then
all of a sudden different musicians
would just come out of the woodwork and
start jamming with me so i'm just like
sweet
and uh
so anyways i'm there and i'm watching
these
this music festival and there's like
three or four stages at this point
in the music festival
and
i remember looking up at the cedar stage
and i was like
wow
those musicians are amazing
i would love
to be up there playing music
well next year i went back
i actually got a job to where i could
change a light up on that stage and i
was like yeah i'm up on the stage
and i'm changing this way you're
resourceful man yeah and so i was just
like yeah i'm there i'm there
you know but then i was just like man i
sure would like to play music but i
think it was the year after that that
this eric nasa guy right here
he saw that i had a set of congas
and he goes like hey what you wanna you
play congress i was like yeah and he
goes we want to come practice with us
and see how he sounds like sure so i
went over and practiced with him and i
just
it's just everything was crisp
and
he said okay he says we're going to be
playing a couple hours you want to play
with us and not watch this
and he was playing on the cedar stage
that one i was looking at a couple years
ago and i was like i wish i could be
that and there i was up there playing
and a buddy of mine took this two years
later i was picturing this was the time
that you paid the change to get in
you paid the change to get in and then
you started probably on the guy yeah
this is like three years after rice wow
that's some dedication man and so now
and now so
now i'm playing up on the stage
and
now when i go back to the music festival
the next year there's other bands out
there saying hey you want to come
practice with us hey you just you know
and so it's like yeah cool you know so i
would i would do that and then you know
so that i would play but then as a
couple years went past that
then
um
i was asked to join a band
and i was like what and i was like are
you guys gonna play earthwork coverage
again they're like yes and i was like
i'm in
i'll do it and so and that's the reason
i joined it so i could play it best but
at this time now it was a play to pay
program so i didn't have to donate any
money or work those long hours anymore
and so now i was getting in getting the
vip treatment you know i get to go
backstage and tap into the kegs and all
that stuff and i was just like and get
to hang out with all the musicians
that's where they were it was like a big
pen of musicians and it was amazing it's
like i'm doing this and so but then
uh so my first band that i was in was
called kimberly mcgorn and the velveteen
bohemians wow that's a mouthful yes it
is it sure is but then
i i kind of went from that one to
another one called the change
and i went from the change to another
one called less older in the ganja gang
wow and but you can't guess what we did
on the stage when we played music
but then
i went from that one
i actually got booted out of that one
and i didn't know it until i showed up
to another music festival you didn't
know it yeah so so i was like i guess i
just didn't read the writing on the wall
or get those subtle hands or whatever
but i showed up to a music festival the
first music festival of that next year
and i think awkwardly it was the leader
of the change that band it was his music
festival and
and they said uh okay
what's up and i was like yeah i'm on i'm
with band you know and they looked on
the list i'm like your name's not on the
list and i was like what
so he called the leader of the band says
hey
mouse bear says you know his name's not
on the list what's going on he's like
he's not my band anymore wow just like
that and so yeah and so now i'm just
like
my dream is just crushed and just like
so i'm in the state and then the guy
that was putting on the music festival
he was like
he said
you can always stick around and work the
music festival if you want and i was
just in the state at that moment i was
just like nobody can see the mouse bear
like this
you know like that's beneath me
but then i went ahead and i uh
so i was driving home just moping i was
just like just like oh just falling
apart falling apart at the seams
and i went ahead and
and then it just dawned on me you need
to call less older and thank him for
allowing you to play in his band
wow yeah and you need you need to do
this and you need to be positive about
it and you
don't show any feelings of
resentment don't don't be negative and
so i did it and i called him yeah and
yeah he answered and i was just like
hey less older i just want to let you
know i thank you so much for letting me
be in your band i said it was so awesome
you guys are great musicians it was
phenomenal
and uh then even then he was kind of
giving me giving me some you know like
he always used to give me something like
other bands would hear it when i wasn't
there and they'd just be like hey
you stop talking about miles bear like
that because you know and they would all
stick up for me
so uh so i guess you know some people
have an ego and some people don't
but uh so anyways so i just continued it
and i just let it play out and then a
couple music festivals i went to after
that i uh another guy walked up to me
super individual dude
super awesome
uh he's about 20 years old
and he just graduated from interlaken
school of music in michigan which is a
very prestigious school up there it's
like
some of the greats have graduated from
up there
and he already had 28 originals in his
back pocket wow and he just knew so many
other songs and he was a phenomenal just
phenomenal performer and he was just so
good
and i walked up to him he's like mouse
bear what's up and he's like man i heard
about the band he's like i'm sorry to
hear about that he's like
what do you think about playing music
with me and i'm just like what
i was like are you for real he's like
yeah he's like you're a cool dude man
everybody that hangs out with you thinks
you're really awesome
you know so you got a great vibe and
he's like i need that in my band and i
was just like cool man well yeah i'd
love to i'd be honored
and so uh
i started playing with this cat and
now
we're getting paid
to play at music festivals because i
guess we just moved leveled up yeah
and so i went ahead and i was just like
this is awesome and then so now we got a
following and there's people following
us from music festival music festival
and it's just like
this is cool
you know and then we're playing we're
getting paid and then we're getting
breaks
from the music festival going to play at
venues and we got paid 500 for playing
at this one venue for like an hour hour
and 15 minutes and then coming back to
the music festival and doing our thing
and so it was like
we're getting paid and getting paid
and so it was just like
and i was like finally this
is where i've always wanted to be this
is what i started off to be i've always
wanted to be a musician to play get paid
take breaks and get paid and come back
yeah so now where are you spiritually at
this point
you started out searching for god and
you kind of had this like a little bit
of a detour
wavering but now music would you say
like that's kind of become your god has
it replaced your desire to actually
seek out god
the uh the thing about the music is that
i was focusing more on my music than i
was with my relationship with god
time for god at this point well at this
point i'm still reading my bible okay um
throughout all this but yeah but not at
the music festivals okay like there was
only one music festival that i went to i
was like this is a place where i need to
read my scriptures while i'm here
and i knew that before going into
pentagrams around and that kind of stuff
you know you see a circle of people in
the woods at night just keep walking it
doesn't happen right come on no way
no way but yeah that's uh then they
outlaw that yeah maybe it burned at the
stake the uh but i went ahead and i did
uh
i got to there was doing the music
festival thing and i was reading my
bible when i came home
every morning and i
and i made a prayer to god
one day and i said god
you got some people going to church on
saturday some people are going to church
on sunday i said once you figure it out
you let me know
that's interesting yeah that's really
interesting you know so you asked god i
mean why why why why this saturday why
would that even come into the question
because i've been to so many different
churches on sunday and
so many different kinds of churches i
mean i even stopped into a catholic
church one day to check it out but it
was
too much standing up sitting down and
they were repeating stuff and i was just
like
all right see you guys later did they
preach in latin i don't know maybe
it was it was because it was foreign
don't they preach in latin still the
mass it's some of them they do
that's the only that's the only time
i've ever actually been inside of a
catholic church so yeah so i i pretty
much i was just
you know i was at
my end and i was just like yeah you know
this is
you know god
you got to show me
what's up what's going on here
so i went ahead and uh i just kept going
going in life and
just playing with this awesome band and
we were just
flower island
you know
that was the name of it yeah flower
island
that leads up to
the day
to where god
i felt i really felt god
if i knew that's right where he was
calling me back now that i look back on
it because i got on youtube and i
started watching different preachers all
on the subject of forgiving
and i was watching these guys and they
were pretty much all agreeing on the
same thing and i learned that
in order to forgive people
all we have to do is forgive them in our
hearts and we don't have to tell them
and i could when i start thinking
getting that angry feeling about
something it's like oh that's not right
this should oh some someone should do
something about this and you know want
to start gossiping about someone
then i would just forgive them and i was
like yes we're supposed to forgive one
another and so and then i would start to
think of people from my past and like
from way back when and way back when and
i was like oh yeah
oh i forgive them and and so after i was
doing this for a little while then
this huge weight was just lifted off my
entire life and it was like i was just
bouncing through life and i was just as
happy as a child again you mean it's
actually a biblical principle it's
amazing it changed my life but isn't
that isn't that just so typical on how
god is with us i mean we have been
forgiven so much in life i mean who
hasn't had a bit of a colored past or
you know indulged into to a sinful life
and it's like we've come to god and he's
so freely given it to us
so to turn around and give it to other
people that's that's really neat that
god was kind of like you know
teaching you these little biblical
principles along the way so amazing
that's clearly more for us than for the
other people right right
yes you're forgetting other people doing
harmful things to you but really it's
you that your spirits are getting lifted
yeah i've described
hating resentment and stuff is like
drinking poison and thinking it's going
to hurt that person because you're like
yeah no i'll never forgive them i hate
them and it's like they have no clue
they're going on with their life but
it's
building up in you it's only causing you
damage and i think what people don't
realize too is it's actually a lot of
work to be angry at someone yeah i mean
it really does take a lot of more energy
and everything i mean you know drains
your day you go home and you feel like
rotten yeah it takes so much more
muscles to frown than it does smile yeah
yeah and instead if you turn it upside
down
so there we were
uh
learning about forgiveness and god was
right by my side that whole time and i
was you know i was actually i was still
going to the bars and stuff like that
still doing my thing smoked weed for 20
years now oh wow yeah so i was a huge
body you weren't addicted though no no
not at all
you can't get addicted to marijuana
if you're smoking marijuana you can't
but if you're not smoking marijuana you
can't yeah it's just how it plays out
right
so the thing is is that uh you didn't
inhale i did not inhale
that's that joke's a little too old yeah
yeah
yeah it is no clinton yeah
after learning how to forgive
thank god i was watching these youtube
channels and all of a sudden i came
across this youtube channel called
school for prophets we know those guys
yeah yeah
how did you randomly come across them i
you know what it was just on my search
engine
youtube recommendations yeah
recommendations youtube actually working
with us sometimes you know
youtube
yeah yeah so now we got uh
i'm i'm saying okay wow school for
profits
so i can go to school to be a prophet
sam yeah
let's do it and so i checked it out and
and i saw he had an animation video
and
what what's it called it's called from
babylon to america yeah
the first one and there's actually two
check both out they're amazing
so i went ahead and i watched that first
one
and it started from the story of nimrod
in the bible and then it went to king
nebuchadnezzar and then it went to
emperor constantine and when it talked
about ever constantine on what he did
and how he gave the power of the pope
inside of the church and brought the
pagan religion in with the christian
religion and they brought both of their
beliefs in there and how they took the
sabbath from the christians and then
took the sunday sun worship from the
pagans and created sunday worship
and
and as soon as i saw it i was like
i asked god for an answer yeah i was
like thank you god
and then it reminded me i'm a man of my
word so i said okay
wow and i got my phone and said okay
google
who worships god on saturday in midland
michigan
all right it's time to go back to church
so simple i love it
yeah wow you'd be surprised by how many
people find you know churches literally
by just googling like you know what
church believes this and then all of a
sudden it's like
but even with that we see how god
continues to follow his method christ's
method you meet the need and then you
bid people to follow christ so in your
life you asked god a question but before
even addressing that god saw hey let me
let me show him forgiveness and teach
him how to forgive someone else to kind
of lift the clouds so you can gain that
clarity that's just amazing and if we
would follow that you know in our
evangelistic efforts meet the need first
before bidding people to follow christ
and and how long was it from the time
that you asked god that question to the
time that this about a year and a half
to two years
so so i think that's an important piece
of the puzzle here is to to not be yeah
to not be just so like i asked you a
question god and you didn't answer and
write him off where it's like sometimes
god needs to lead you on a path and then
you're ready to accept that because he
he knows the timing he knows where your
heart's at so he's working on your heart
a little bit yeah he's opening it up and
then he's like yeah i'm gonna drop this
truth bomb on you bam
he knows the beginning from the end yeah
and it is amazing and he just knows
exactly the path that
how he works in each of in our hearts
and so praise god he is so good he is so
good so so there i am i'm i'm uh i'm
going back to church now all right and
i'm like okay i'm gonna go check this
out so i'm driving to church i'm the god
please don't let them
bug me to be baptized into their church
every church i went to that's all
they've done is
get baptized become a member be part of
our family
i'm like i'm going back to church please
don't let them do this
and so i get into the church and i'm i
get there for a day and i'm greeted by
a wonderful woman
who goes to church there
named ardis
and uh she just made me feel real
welcomed
she later on i found out she was the
deaconess of the church i was like
right now and doing a good job good work
and so i went ahead and
i
got done with the church and
talked to a couple people and then got
out into my car and grabbed my bowl
packed it full of marijuana
okay drove out of the parking lot wait
for the church to get the rear view
mirror anybody around nope okay
doing my thing i've been doing it for
years
praise god i never got caught
but
so and i've been doing this and then
friday comes along
time to hang out with my homeboy in
midland and got a deal
if i drive him and his car
from bar to bar he buys all the drinks
so i'm just like sign me up
so i'm doing that and saturday back to
coleman hang out with the other group
let's go drinking let's have a good time
and
week two goes by so you didn't go back
to church the next week or something i
did you're in church in the daytime but
the night time you're hanging yeah
i was living that double yeah a double
life in the world
yeah and so the second weekend i go back
there
repeat same thing i'm hanging you feel
at this point do you feel like what
you're doing is is wrong or do you i
know it is i know it is but i know i
made a promise to god that i would start
going back to church if he
told me the truth
and so i was like okay i'm doing this
and so i'm just doing it and after two
weeks it's about two and a half weeks
now
that i'm going to church and then i'm
hanging out at home and i just grew my
first marijuana plant
it's illegal in michigan i'm just like
yeah let's do this illegal in michigan
yeah oh yeah it sure is michigan is a
blue state the whole state's going to
pod
so i went ahead and
and i picked up i was in my bedroom and
i picked my mason jar off
just full of marijuana that i just grew
from the street harvest and i was like
just turn it back and forth in the glass
watching it sparkle
and i said god
as soon as i'm done smoking this i'll be
done smoking marijuana forever
and i set it down on the bed stand there
and i went to take a step and before my
foot hit the ground
god's presence
just surrounded all around me it was the
amazingest feeling in my whole life
and he said he communicated with me just
for clarification you're not on anything
yeah i'm not i'm not this is the real
deal this is only like one of three
times that this has happened to me and
all of a sudden god's presence comes all
around me and i just feel him and he
communicates with me and he says paul
if you don't stop smoking marijuana
right now you'll never stop
wow and i picked it up and i looked at
it and i was like all right
so i went and i threw it out in the
trash
and i went and gathered all my
paraphernalia and i do it in the trash i
was like all right god i trust in you
i'm gonna stop i love that how personal
god is you know you weren't listening to
some sermon and it was like this moving
sermon he's like now take your
your paraphernalia and smash it it was
just you and god
i had that experience too i love that
you know that you don't have to be in a
church and
not just not to sway people from not
doing that
but it's just awesome i think there's
something more to it when
it's just you and god because you open
your heart and you communicate with him
and you know you build this relationship
with him and it's like you know you
don't
he's not waiting for you to like come
clean come into his environment he's
gonna communicate with you and he'll
clean you up yeah yeah isn't it a
beautiful thing it's awesome you know
what's up brother
so uh
so yeah so now i'm i'm and i decided to
give up alcohol too because i went to uh
school for profits again and i was like
and i was looking i was like i thought
he had some
something on there that says don't
don't drink or don't do marijuana
because of something i was looking for
marijuana marijuana and i looked for it
and i saw it and i was like yeah yeah he
sure did
and so i was like okay so all right
marijuana is not good and so and this is
like i think this is like right before i
the lord i had that moment with him
and so i went ahead
and now i'm going back to church and i'm
sharing all the good news with everybody
i'm like yeah i'm not smoking my mom
anymore i'm not drinking you know this
stuff is having it's cool and it was
literally just cold turkey yeah yeah see
the thing was the power of god the power
of christ just comes inside
and he takes away the desire all we have
to do
is just ask him to come into our lives
and to have that moment with us and just
give it all to him and he'll do it it's
so amazing
it's so amazing i mean there was like
maybe one or two times within the first
six months that i quit where i was like
oh man if i just smoke a joint right now
if i just smoke this doobie i can you
know this will take care of this that's
your old man trying to come out of there
right yeah
get back in there so i went ahead and uh
so i decided to quit smoking marijuana
and drinking at the same time right
there
and so now i'm going back to church i'm
telling everybody yeah you know this is
cool this is working out in my life and
and then about
about a week after that or maybe a week
a week and a half
i am
i'm at home and i'm sitting there i'm
just kind of hanging out all by myself
and
all of a sudden
the power of god comes around again
surrounds me do you hear any sounds in
the background like no no no
and when that feeling came around me i
was like i know what this is
interesting and god he communicated with
me
and he says
hey
how's your music going
and i said god it's going amazing i was
like this is everything that i've worked
so hard for all these years
it's going so fantastic we got a fan
base
we're getting paid to play and we're
going we're taking breaks and we're
playing out at vendors and coming back
to the music festival it's everything
i've ever wanted
and he was like good for you he's like
good for your accomplishment you got to
do everything you want to do he's like
right on and i was just like right on
and he said uh then he he says can i ask
you a question i said we'll shoot
he says are you doing it for your glory
or for my glory no it's like
wow yeah that's when you hear it
record scratch
and so
and i was like
i said uh
i'm doing it for my glory god
and he says well since you got to do it
and you got to experience it
what do you think about coming on over
and playing for my glory
wow so i said yeah yeah i will uh
i'll do that and uh
and so i called up the leader of the
band
that i was in flower island
and i said trent buddy i love you i love
you so much and i'm so glad that you
invited me to be in your band
i love playing music with you i love the
fact that we got all these followers i
love the fact that we're getting paid
and then we get paid and i said and i
love hanging out with your family after
we do it and butter them up yeah just
mic dropped i love playing pool with
your family when we're just everybody's
hanging out having cookouts and
everything like that it's it's such a
beautiful thing it's everything i've
ever wanted to do you've made my dreams
come true
and so i went ahead and told him that
and he goes yeah i love you mouse fair
you know and i was like yeah i love you
too buddy i said however
i need to pull out of the band he's like
oh what
he's like did i do anything what what'd
i do and i was like it wasn't you
i says i said i'm just i'm going down a
different path right now i'm following
god wow and he goes wait wait wait we
could play christian music oh wow and i
was like bro that's so wonderful for you
to say that yeah but the spirit is
willing and the flesh is weak
i mean we're living a certain life we're
going a certain way
you know i got knocked out of my boots
you know with for god and so now i'm
just like you know
the spirit is willing but the flesh is
weak i said yeah
maybe but probably not and so
and i just kept telling how much i loved
him after that and then i hung up the
phone and i was done i was done with the
music festival journey that i went on
and i decided and but
before i knew what i was doing i wrote a
song
called thin air lies
and
it talks a little bit about you know you
guys had a lot of influence in
what i wrote yeah 100 yeah because it
was great well cam can we hear the song
yeah you want to hear the sound i want
to hear it all right you want to hear it
yeah
i'd love to share the piece of music
with you guys
here it is
is this all you like
right yeah i wrote this i'm playing and
singing it
[Music]
don't drink the haterade
on television
[Music]
there's a magic wizard
hide behind the curtain
he weighs his wand
[Music]
over the nations
they're mongering
[Music]
until the people are hurting
don't believe everything
that you hear
[Music]
make it clear
don't believe everything
[Music]
that you hear
their lies
make it clear
[Music]
they say the angels are coming
they're gonna show us a sign
[Music]
make us feel all right
deep down inside
[Music]
talk about a piece
aligned in time
gather us together
[Music]
and take us for a ride
don't believe everything
[Music]
that you hear
make it clear
[Music]
don't believe everything
that you hear
their lies
make it clear
[Music]
there's a mother church
full of tradition
[Music]
with his harlot daughters
place in position
[Music]
the seed is planted
and conscience freedom
for the common goods
final deception
[Music]
don't believe everything
that you hear
[Music]
[Laughter]
make it clear
don't believe everything
that you hear
their lies
[Music]
make it clear
don't believe everything
that you hear
[Music]
[Laughter]
make it clear
[Music]
what i really like about it is
that you're
you're passionate about what you do you
can see it in the music and then you're
also understanding that music is a
teaching tool
and so you're incorporating your
creativity with actually going let me
give you something that's that's a
that's a that's a solid substance to
listen to you know it's something that's
going to make you think and
um as you were sitting here explaining
kind of what some of those verses
actually meant you can tell there's a
lot of you know bible study a lot of
prophecy a lot of you know end time
events type of things that you just
layered into this little song and i
think it's beautiful yeah i wrote this
right after i read the great controversy
the battle between god and satan yeah
which is a book that really has a
a beautiful historical account
from you know how the church really you
know
developed apostasized developed and you
know like all the different dynamics
that have gone through the dark ages and
how truth that line of truth has
actually made it to us today in our
modern study i read that as a young kid
as well and um was very blessed by it so
need to hear
yeah so what i did what happened is
this is
i wrote this one piece right here
and then it just then it finally clicked
in it and i was just like
oh yeah
i'm supposed to go from secular world to
god and i was like i was hoping this
would be a transitional piece right here
and then it dawned on me it was like
you've been trained
how to write music
from a worldly perspective
and the book that you got songwriting
for dummies took all the examples out
from the greats before you and
this is all you know
you don't know how to write music for
god you haven't been taught how to do
that the right way
so i pretty much put my guitar down
and just kind of looked at it for a
while and now i'm still waiting because
god answers prayers
yes
it's amazing i'm going to go back to one
thing as we were kind of
bringing this thing
toward its end
you mentioned at one point though that
you knew what you were doing was wrong
you know you you knew what you were
doing was wrong you you went down that
path but
at the same time
when
the truth became
evident
you were willing to
let go of what you wanted to do and
follow what god had called you to do you
can see the struggle of
you can see the holy spirit at work
right you know the holy spirit convicts
us of sin
and of righteousness
right you can see that two-fold process
in your life and you knew you knew it
was wrong you've been convicted of sin
but then when the holy spirit is like
you know this is the way i walk you in
it
you were you were ready to go
what um
what what was that tipping point what
what you know tipped it over it's like
you know it's wrong but then
if you know it's wrong what what
causes you to just flip the switch
you know it was nothing that i did
it wasn't any of my power
it was all the power of christ because
when he started coming into my life when
he answered that prayer that i had and i
decided to follow him after that
very slowly but surely he'd take one
thing out of my life as soon as he would
take that out of my life then he would
just come into the temple and he would
just shine some more light and i'd just
be like
oh so as you followed up truth he
revealed more truth yeah and i was like
what about that and then then he would
just continually just
give me the power to take this out of my
life and then he would come in more and
more so it would just continue to happen
like that and all of a sudden it's just
like i need to get rid of all this stuff
yeah and so yeah so i just
yeah he gave me the power to do all of
it how
early on in your experience you were
talking about your bible study component
so you know you're talking about you
you'd go to the the
um
the festivals and and
you know there was one you you read your
bible others you know maybe maybe not so
much and so it was kind of like this
you'd be reading the bible at what
point or in as you got to this point
were you reading the bible more
when i was reading the bible more is
when
when i when god started cleaning up my
act and the pastor of the church
he uh actually came over one day i
you know you send that book when you
come into church you're like okay guess
book you're a guest yeah so i signed
that guest book
and
then i actually put the wrong number on
there
so the pastor's trying to call my phone
number and he's leaving me these
messages
if it's your number if it's your number
i'm sorry about that that's a good
pastor that followed through yeah the
face of oh you could easily dismiss that
i couldn't get a hold of him
you know he gave me bogus information
i'm gonna actually show up with this
address even yeah so here comes this guy
i don't even remember ever seeing him
again he's he actually has two churches
sister churches that he passes at so i
didn't know he's a pastor but i saw him
carrying his bible
up the sidewalk one day and i was just
like all right this guy gets to come in
right yeah anybody who has a bible you
come on in and so i was sitting there
and i was cooking
uh biscuits and gravy you know oh pork
and so
and i was cooking it and i let him in
and i said hey how's it going because
i'm the pastor of the church that you
started going to i was like oh wonderful
come on in i was like
i said i made enough for two
and he sat down and he ate that biscuit
gravy with me wow and as a testimony to
me
and that helped me later on
when it come
to
not offend other people
to win their when their trust to win
their affection
it's just like jesus does you know and
it's just like and so he choked it down
and yeah yeah but uh and then yeah so it
was super awesome super awesome that he
came up there and he so what he did is
he was
coming to me and then he's like oh hey
you know
and he sit there and he'll talk to me
for a little bit and then so what do you
think about maybe doing some some
studies and stuff like that and then we
got into the discipleship book after a
while and we started doing that and then
so now
it's about
three months two three months into the
church and i'm just like
hey can i be baptized in your church
and
and so he uh he's like yeah he goes he
goes i i can tell in your life that
you're putting these things out and
you're stopping this and that you're
growing in christ and he says but let's
go through some more of these bible
studies so we know what we're getting
into before we jump into it and so
i was just like i was like cool i mean
you're the pastor you know what you're
talking about he didn't hound you about
getting baptized and joined the church
i think it's just so neat to hear your
story of how you felt the yearning and
you started responding to the yearning
and slowly gently god was working with
you and it was really that you you just
wanted to follow christ right amen i
think it's very ironic that keith is
wearing a follow shirt
you know what i mean it's just great
that's what we're called to do is just
follow god follow christ want him in our
heart and let him let him work out the
details of those things that need to get
changed god's not waiting for us to
change then follow him we need to follow
him amen brother
say that you made a point i just want
you to bring it home because there might
be someone watching who
who's in a band or a musical group right
they're studying their bible and they
truly believe that what they're doing
the band activities they're engaging in
is for god so can you talk about why it
was important for you to not only give
your heart to christ but to leave the
band
and to follow you know each step god was
taking you
the first question why it was important
to give my heart to god as well as leave
it you leave the band as well as leave
the band well i knew i couldn't have
both
i had to
how did you know i i knew because
when i was playing in the band
i was
smoking pot i was drinking heavily you
know i had to convince myself after a
while don't start drinking until the sun
goes down because i just couldn't
you know don't drink until after you
perform because it was i mean to be
sometimes when i was up on stage and i'm
just playing the congress and just
sweating and
all of a sudden i disappear and then i
come back and i'm just like
is this really happening is this
i'm up here like oh wow look at all the
people so great so i was just like
but i think it was it's so important
because if
if we keep that old
luggage with us that we have and we
carry it with us and we try to have a
relationship with god
we're not we're not weighing out the
circumstances because god tells us
you know follow me you know don't don't
worry about all this other stuff i i
think that's a really good point because
when when jesus
asked the disciples you know he's not
just asking him to like
you know leave being a fisherman and
just you know whatever but i think he
understood that same sort of thing too
you're gonna compete with this old life
gotta make money gotta do the grind
gotta do whatever it is to to make that
thing work when god's like going no i
want your dependency on me
and i will help you and so yeah to clear
out the whole you know mess and start
fresh and be like okay god whatever you
got in store for me and then i even like
the fact that you're not trying to smash
your creativity into going out and
serving god you're just like okay i'm
gonna take a step back from this and
wait until you tell me god yeah because
you should be doing it because you
because you've done that you know this
is our voyage now
it's so awesome
to just have patience for god it's so
awesome
to
to be able to trust in him and allow him
to lead me in my life
it's uh
it's super amazing i'm just so grateful
isn't there a weight on the lord verse
yeah
yeah but but you you know
you
god was patient with you yes you know
and so you
you can be patient with others
and the people that he put in your life
it sounds like they were really patient
with you nobody was like
really trying to push you one way or
another they were just like let let it
take its course thank you for bringing
it back because that's exactly what i
need to say and i wanted to say is that
god
from the beginning
to the end knows exactly what he's doing
all we have to do is just
jump on that train and just be like yep
i'm totally for god and just trust in
him because
at that moment in my life he surrounded
me with his presence for the first time
in my life and he communicated with me
and i was just like
bam huge awesome okay god thank you you
know i've waited this long so this is
what's up and then god's workers come in
so every time you have somebody that
comes into your life and tries to help
you out that's god working in your life
and he wants you to be there to
experience this path in your life he
wants you to be on board with us and
that's what happened to me is that and i
had just god was working from so many
different aspects of my life and i was
just like
there's no way i could pass this one up
no way and he reached you in a way that
he knew that you would hear because all
of us sitting at this table were here
but we came different ways god addressed
us in different ways and that's
incredible so you don't necessarily have
to be looking for the white light yeah
but what in what areas are you missing
god's voice is it you may be
listening
isn't it
amazing just on how we can't even
understand how amazing it is we can just
only even maybe think about it but then
it's just like
no you don't you want to look behind the
veil you just you want to take your time
and you want to learn about it so one
last question yeah
you had a taste of this
you have a taste of this right
what's what's sweeter what's sweeter
god is
god is the sweetest station life brother
amen he is amen he is hands down no
explanation
he really is it's it's so freeing it's
so
i
trust in jesus and now i don't have to
worry about everything else
he gives you the desires of your heart
yeah even things you didn't think you
needed or wanted or that would even make
you happy but when you trust in him yes
he has your best interest at heart god
is good and what a great conversation
thank you so much for sharing your story
with us yeah thanks for having me guys
so if somebody wants to listen to
some of the pieces that you've created
how do we even listen to it or can we
led live yeah the link is below the
description
do you have a youtube channel i do not
okay i do not but uh
maybe
this is the only piece i have for now
um i mean i have other pieces but
they're not pivotal point pieces yeah
and uh yeah but when god
finds it right yeah in his time yeah
then i'll start back up and i'll be able
to
offer some more pieces but for now
i trust in the lord maybe someday we'll
get a uh
a follow-up show and you'll be able to
show us where god has led from this
point front row tickets
thank you for sharing your story
i was inspired when i met you and uh
yeah it's been a joy and honor and uh so
we hope you guys uh had a blessed time
listening to
mouse bear paul terry's story here
and uh you know keep him in your prayers
we're all on a journey right but you
know the one take-home that i believe
that came out of this conversation is
listen if you trust in god and literally
just open your heart to him honestly he
will direct your past he will he will
lead you in ways of righteousness and
he'll take care of the things that we
need to cut out of our lives and uh he
really wants that relationship with you
so just open your heart to him and you
will not be sorry thanks for watching
led live we'll see you next week
visit our brothers at school for
prophets dot tv and watch from babylon
to america which has over 5 million
views on youtube alone and follow it up
with america 2 babylon check the
description below for links to this and
more
[Music]
you